in Wisconsin starts us off this hour at
least so how are you hiding thanks so
much for having us on
certainly know well I'm calling because
there is some stress going on in our
home right now I quit my job before we
had our surprise fourth baby to stay
home with him we just decided that was
the best situation for our family and
then we bought a new home but we are
already in contract for her buildings
and the same months we had the baby we
went through a few that same month too
and realize they're kind of a mess and
we got on a budget and I'm so home with
our baby and I'm forgetting stressed out
because our property taxes are going to
become part of our mortgage payment
coming next month and we're still
working on paying off debt and my
husband really wants me to go back to
work and I do too but I'm we're just
wondering is it something that I should
rush into and find something right away
or is it okay to take a month or two and
use some savings to kind of get us
through and put on the right fit for our
family
what's your house payment $2,700 what's
your household take-home pay
it's about without my husband's bonus
this is $100,000 a year and then he gets
a bonus every year that's somewhere
between ten to twenty thousand dollars
okay and so you have a hundred and
twenty thousand dollar income
approximately and so he should be taking
home about eight thousand dollars a
month average throughout the year but
your typical month is more like six
thousand or a little more right it's
about on our budget it's what six
thousand dollars even every month
yeah plus you've got another twenty
thousand coming into the end the year
okay and how much dad how much debt do
you have not counting your home
our student loan debt is our only that
you've paid off everything else and
that's at $90,000 that's it how much
90,000 $90,000 okay yeah okay and you
have four kids and so what I said you
have four children so what is uh what is
the path that he's on what does he do
for a living he's in the financial world
the path that his income is on is going
up rapidly or gently I would say I
he would say gently I would say rapidly
he's doubled it in the last five years
okay that's we don't know if it'll
double it again but it but it's going to
go up another 20,000 or 30,000 soon yeah
in the next couple of years I would
anticipate yes yeah
and so his angst over all of this is
just his intensity to get out of debt
it's not actually can you feed your
family no it's it's to get out of debt
and he's total but told you the nerd and
I'm the free spirit and then on his
spreadsheet and he sees that and it
stresses him out he needs to quit
stressing out okay I want you to be
intense intense is different than
stressed okay and there's nothing to be
stressed out here the numbers you're
giving me are not disastrous you have a
ten thousand dollar household income net
of tax are $8,000 net of taxes so your
house payments a little high but not for
long because your incomes coming up and
so you guys are not going to make a lot
of debt progress this year but probably
next year you will and that's okay
the other option is sell your house and
move into a more affordable home
we we bought we bought the home more
than a die-in
that's absolute bull crap that's bull
crap there's no such thing
you're too young to have done that your
life is going to change 14 times between
now and then the it's just a house don't
don't attention don't you attach it is
just a and you know I really wouldn't
trade your house for you being home with
those kids since that is the desire of
your heart you did not call me up and
say I love being a professional woman in
the marketplace making money I am dying
to go back to work you called me up and
said I'm willing to because my husband's
freaking out but my initial desire was
to stay home when I had the fourth child
that's what you told me you don't want
to go back to work and before I went
back to work if I were in your shoes I'd
sell your house and move down but I
don't think you have to do either one oh
I think your husband's just probably
take a chill pill and you guys push on
through this what did you what did you
do for a living he doesn't want to stop
interesting to his 401k well he's not
following well no I know yeah so there's
a problem okay I mean listen you can't
call me up and ask my advice on part of
the program if you're not going to the
other part it doesn't worry I'm not a
mom yeah I mean for him it doesn't work
he can't he can't use me to send you
back to work because he won't stop his
dadgum 401k now I'm getting pissed I
mean really he wants you to go back to
work to fund his 401k that's what we
just heard now that's what completely
out of line when your desire is to be at
home with these four kids okay
he really needs to take a chill pill
really and he is living in math and
forgets that math is there to serve his
family his wife and his children are why
we do math not so that we win the
spreadsheet Wars so no absolutely not
okay yeah you guys are trying to do too
many things at one time you bought a
house you couldn't afford you want to
to 401k why you have $90,000 in debt and
you'd like to get out of debt oh and
you'd like to stay home with four
children these are for things that are
incongruent you're gonna have to not do
some of them in order to get the other
ones done and you get to decide which
ones because you're grownups personally
I'd stop the stupid 401k chill on the
getting out of debt just a little bit
until his income comes on up and keep
that house or I talk about selling that
house bottom of the list of four for me
is sending you back to work that's the
question you call me to ask that's my
answer
thanks for calling in open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five number one thing that keeps you
from accomplishing your goals is not
what you're willing to do to hit your
goals it's what you're willing to give
up to hit your goals you have to be able
to not do things that are in congruent
with your goals to hit your goals or you
never hit them whatever the goal is
chocolate chip cookies are incongruent
with me losing weight can't have both
get to choose which one and that that's
what we got here we got a stack of
incongruent things